[Musik]
das ist die adresse die karte für
einbrüche bitte ja verstanden wie sie
die situation aus vor ungefähr 20
minuten sei der informant zwei
einbrecher auf seiner videoüberwachung
und es besteht der verdacht dass sie
einen roller gestohlen haben
signale mend drei junge mit
jogginganzügen und her
im moment haben wir nicht mehr auf dem
segment ist eine farbige und eine weiße
person
[Musik]
es sind schon kollegen vor ort ein
einbruch in einer villa oberhalb von
loser alltag der waadtländer polizei
das passiert etwa 20 mal pro tagen
kannte die forensiker sind bereits da um
spuren sicher zu stellen
man hält die erkenntnisse fest und die
zeugenaussage des opfers venus sachen
glaube die haben den computer
mitgenommen
der roller stand dort die häme waren
drin
ich denke dass es sie benutzten sie
nahmen die häme den stürzten die papiere
die dazu gehören
gehen sie nicht rein und die spuren zu
sichern
doch sofort wie bei sie es werden
sorgfältig die fingerabdrücke genommen
die spuren der täter
ich habe den abdruck der spitze einer
handfläche genommen
wir haben also einen teil eines
handabdruck das ist eine relativ gute
spur
die reden gut sehen die kleinen linien
auf der hand diese spuren erlauben es
die diebe zu identifizieren und sie mit
den delikten in verbindung zu bringen
plötzlich ist draußen ein roller zu
hören die einbrecher sind aus ihrem
versteck gekommen und versuchen zu
fliehen
da geht es hinauf
[Musik]
wenn es wieder abwärts geht müsst ihr
euch beeilen und zurück wenn es dort
runter geht gibt es einen aufprall kommt
zurück
die polizeiautos nehmen sofort die
verfolgung auf
aber die mühe ist vergeblich die diebe
entkommen diese serien einbrüche sind
schwer zu stoppen
die polizei kommt immer zu spät deshalb
versuchen jetzt einige polizei kurs die
delikte vorherzusehen um so den
einbrechern zuvorzukommen
in zürich los angeles und mailand ist
diese vorhersage von verbrechen keine
zukunftsvision mehr sondern realität
[Musik]
zürich hinter den traditionellen
fassaden ist eine unsichtbare revolution
im gange
dank mathematischer formeln kann die
polizei die nächsten verbrechen
vorhersagen bevor sie überhaupt begangen
werden prekop spray crime obsession
heißt dieses system
dieser mann hat die installation im jahr
2013 geleitet daten über frühere
einbrüche wurden in den computer
eingegeben so konnte ein muster
berechnet werden
die idee dank der vergangenheit kann man
die zukunft vorhersagen wie ist ein
täter vorgegangen welche spuren hat er
hinterlassen
all diese ermittlungstechnischen
informationen kommen in das system der
polizei wichtige eckdaten kommen dann zu
dominik balog dem chef des lagezentrums
das system britpops analysiert einbrüche
und stellte eine prognose für
unmittelbare folge einbrüche früh
soundsystem jetzt front wo man halt das
muster hat mussten sich überzeugt dass
im bereich von der masse delikt das in
der regel vermögensdelikt bedeutet wie
zu spielbeginn gewaltverbrechen wo sehr
häufig oder emotionen dahinter sehen der
spontan sind
das systemhaus mit leichter
einbrüche sind für ein krieg ob system
besonders geeignet fläche über 400 230
weniger stellen wir jede menge ziel und
entsprechend viel übrig und wenn man so
lebt haben das gefühl die findet überall
statt dem flohmarkt im unteren
bildschirm stellt man fest dass die ihr
nicht gleichförmig verteilt sind
überzieht sondern dass es zu schwer pink
und ihr seid dem hotspot mit center
unterwegs seid dass sie den schwerpunkt
zur geburt und wo es vermehrt zu
folgende liegt vor sanierte und wenn man
die summe gebiete in einen ehebruch
feststellen dort marschieren eigentlich
steckt dort für die mibrag analysieren
und lockt die höhere wahrscheinlichkeit
für das volk genau dem prognosewert
dieses phänomen der zeitnahen
wiederholung ist statistisch bewiesen
es basiert auf den menschlichen drang
nach gewinnmaximierung wenn ich jetzt in
wald garner bild findet dann kann ich
zum nächsten feld und hof irgendwo eine
sonderlich traurig wie das volk ab
solange ich nicht dass ich gefühle
eigentlich guten ebracher vor wo bleibt
die erfahrung der polizisten wird die
ganze verantwortung an die maschine
übergeben
das know-how start für manche aufgrund
von täterverhalten und das virus auch
geeignet hand sie stehen dort dann
einfach stark filter anhand der merkmale
und noch den vorschlag der mensch muss
aber immer entscheiden und zeigen wie
gut die prognose oder eben seg evaristo
lüthi setzte oder war das nicht
außerdem entscheidet die merkmale hat
man damit ermittler wo man bestimmen hat
gesagt was macht das delikt wohnen
professionelle eine weiter begehrt wie
nie wirklich braucht wie genau es ist
vorgehen will putin nimmt damit und das
ist im normalfall ein mensch relativ
lang hat wenn er das vitale und
probieren user ist das jetzt ein profi
oder überhöht und da hilft maschinen
stark in dem sehr viel sekundenschnelle
sobald die dort diene sind das kommt
themen und 2 grad für die gartenstadt
der maschine prognose arbeit gemacht hat
der erfahrene polizist verifiziert das
war der höchste sieg hand machen wir so
einen ausdruck wo man auch der front
politisch den abgrund der weniger
wertstoffe folge delikte sind innerhalb
von ein bis zwei tagen am
wahrscheinlichsten
wen oder was sie kontrollieren
entscheiden die patroullieren selbst
zürcher polizei gibt es im durchschnitt
seither bis zu 25 prozent weniger
delikte wirklich kausal nachweisen lässt
sich das nicht das problem wie kann man
den erfolg für etwas messen das gar
nicht stattgefunden hat der letzte
einbruch nehmen und das folge delikt
erwarten natürlich klarer erfolgreiches
delikte und dann hätte die maschinen am
irak positiv wird berechnet genau das
delikt waren wir aber verhindern und das
ist jetzt aber situation nur angenehme
situation wo man als trainer befindet
wählen die bürger das nicht stattfindet
der wissenschaftler oder diego analytik
leichter stoff findet zum zeigen wenn
die maschine hamburg rechnet und der
polizist wird am herzen ein täter
verhaftet
[Musik]
ein computer macht prognosen für die
polizei wie funktioniert er um das
system besser zu verstehen
begeben wir uns an die eth lausanne hier
erlauben es die heutigen rechner enorme
massen von informationen zu verarbeiten
das schlüsselwort heißt algorithmus kaum
jemand weiß was das ist
und doch ziehen sie überall wir haben
denn direktor des neuen bundes zentrums
für big data gebeten es uns zu erklären
vielleicht beginnen wir mit einer etwas
trockenen definition ein algorithmus ist
eine endliche und unzweideutiger abfolge
von anweisungen die darauf abzielen ein
ergebnis zu erhalten oder einzulösen
nehmen wir als beispiel ein kochrezept
anfang dieses algorithmus die zutaten
die folgenden anweisungen bestehen aus
braten backen unter anderem um ein
vorbereitetes gericht zu erhalten
der algorithmus ist also das rezept und
die daten sind die zutaten
wir ignorieren algorithmen oft aber wir
benutzen sie jeden tag algorithmen sind
in der tat bei facebook beispielsweise
ermöglichte algorithmus das erkennen und
zuordnen von gesichtern der amazon
algorithmus ermöglicht es ihnen produkte
für den bau vorzuschlagen und zu
empfehlen
der algorithmus erkennt ihre präferenzen
das finden sie überall im fall der
prädiktiven polizeiarbeit zeigt der
algorithmus seine wahrscheinlichkeit auf
das eine straftat begangen wird werden
wir eines tages sogar gewissheit haben
sowie in dieser futuristischen serien
sie werden überwacht der regierung
besitzt ein geheimes system eine
maschine die spioniert sie aus tag und
nacht ohne unterlass die maschine sieht
alles gewalttätige verbrechen die
normale bürger wie sie betreffen
verbrechen für die sich die regierung
nicht interessiert in der serie person
of interest ist die maschine fähig unser
verhalten vorherzusagen
nichts entgeht ihr zieht unsere zukunft
ähnlich aus um das zu erfahren muss man
in die usa reisen
[Musik]
wenn es einen ort gibt wo sich dieser
visionen realisieren könnte dann ist es
hier in los angeles
hier wo alles angefangen hat
[Musik]
es ist schichtwechsel
diese polizisten werden im quartier am
cut auf streife gehen
eines der gewalttätigsten viertel der
stadt territorium der latino gangs und
des drogenhandels
die polizei ist schwer bewaffnet auch
wenn sich die nachbarschaft verändert
hat und viel weniger gewalttätig ist als
noch in den 90er jahre alten butt esther
patrouilliert seit 20 jahren in der
stadt
er ist spezialist im kampf gegen banden
seit fünf jahren hat er einen neuen
spitze sein name red predictive politik
wohin gehen wir
schauen wir mal nach wir gehen in den
nördlichen abschnitt eines unserer prep
voll gebiete vor der zweiten und lukas
wir wissen dass in dieser gegend viel
auto einbrüche und diebstähle vorrunden
und auch autoklau dort also mögliche
verbrechen
dank alter informationen aparte
verhaftungen wissen wir dass diese gegen
einen höheren prozentsatz an verbrechen
aufweist
wir schauen uns jetzt die risiko zone an
die maschine hat angezeigt dass hier
etwas passieren sollte
und tatsächlich in der gegend wurde ein
verdächtiger mann verhaftet
aber der abend ist er ruhig das ergebnis
ein dutzend polizisten um einen einzigen
mann zu kontrollieren
können sie eine maschine vertrauen die
ihnen sagt wohin sie ihre patrouillen
schicken sollen red pol basiert auf
unseren eigenen daten der letzten zehn
jahre
wenn ich nein sagen würde würde das
heißen dass die polizei rapporte falsch
sind
das sind sie nicht deshalb muss die
informationen richtig sein
sie basiert auf unseren daten aus zehn
jahren hätten all das team hat die
geschichten vergangener verbrechen in
die maschine eingegeben ortzeit
vorgehensweise beute
täglich werden die daten aktualisiert
der algorithmus berechnet dann seine
vorhersagen aber funktioniert es
wirklich das wichtigste resultat ist das
zu etwa 10 bis 20 prozent ein gebiet
vorhergesagt wird in dem tatsächlich ein
verbrechen gestellt
das system hat also seine arbeit getan
wenn ich es nicht verhindere lautet die
frage habe ich meine arbeit getan
captain nolte ist einer der ersten der
diese technologie 2011 getestet hat
jetzt wird brad paul von allen
polizeikorps sie in los angeles
verwendet die kosten bis zu 150000
dollar pro jahr
abhängig von der größe der polizei in
rembert ist man stolz auf dieses neue
hightech tun
es gibt der polizei ein image von
modernität und effizienz und auf dem
papier sind die ergebnisse der letzten
acht hatten wir keine diebstähle
einbrüche oder gestohlene autos auf
dieser gebiets karte für die letzten 24
stunden hatten wir nichts ja das wundert
retten wenn du wieder gegend präsent
bist wird das verbrechen verhindert das
glauben sie ich glaube das wirklich je
größer die polizeipräsenz desto geringer
die kriminalität
das hat sich immer wieder bestätigt
besonders mit ton
nur schon die präsenz der polizisten
hält von einbrüchen die präsenz in der
zone wo sie mit leuten reden oder
vorbeifahren
die leute sehen das und wenn die
polizisten ungefähr wissen wohin sie
gehen sollen dann ist nur schon eine 10
prozentige reduktion der delikte ein
großer erfolg
das glauben man weiß dass mehr
polizeipräsenz eine abschreckende
wirkung hat aber pratt falls algorithmus
geht noch weiter er nimmt auch
zukünftige verbrechen vorweg
das system wurde 2010 im gehirn dieses
professor von der universität von los
angeles geboren
er begann mit einer einfachen idee der
mensch würde seine verbrechen in der
umgebung wiederholen so wie er es nach
einem erdbeben nachbeben gibt in der tat
gibt es bei erdbeben die genau gleichen
mechanismen es gibt auch in
kriminalfällen hintergrund ereignisse
und wiederholungs ereignisse oder
nachbeben
das bedeutet dass man die mathematik aus
den erdbeben studiendirektor verbrechen
anwenden kann mit nur geringen
zusätzlichen modifikationen
so wurde die prädiktive polizeiarbeit
geboren und dieser neue ansatz könnte
die polizei von morgen revolutionieren
für die leute ist es schwierig den
gedanken zu akzeptieren dass der ort
viel wichtiger ist als die person
wenn wir an verbrecher denken sind wir
beeinflusst von den medien fernsehshows
und kinofilmen
da geht es immer um den täter und seine
pathologie das führt dazu dass wir alle
glauben es liegt in der persönlichkeit
des täters das ein verbrechen aber um
herauszufinden wo und wann die höchste
wahrscheinlichkeit für ein verbrechen
besteht zählt am schluss der ort viel
mehr
und darauf haben wir uns konzentriert
auf den ort in rembert paypal seine
vorhersagen berechnet morgen geht die
treppe informationen hier also wird die
bread ball karte übergeben wir geben sie
den polizisten und stellen sicher dass
die geeigneten ressourcen in die gegend
mit den meisten zwischenfällen gehen
sie gehorchen der maschine die sagt
wohin er predigt iwes politik diktiert
uns wohin wir diese einheiten schicken
sollen wir gehen zurück in richtung
einer der von red bull angegebenen
risikozonen
ein dutzend rote quadrate sind auf der
karte des bezirks erschienen
sie sind sehr genau 150 meter auf 150
meter und sein boot esther wer
tatsächlich zu einer intervention
gerufen konnten mitglieder
das gericht hatte ihnen verboten sich zu
versammeln
meine kollegen haben einen oder zwei
gangmitglieder identifiziert sie gingen
hin um sie zu stoppen und die wollten
tatsächlich abbauen
die polizisten konnten nicht alle auf
einmal erwischen sie waren genau an der
grenze der pratt polz ohne aber
vermutlich gingen sie die straße runter
genau in die zone 1
diese intervention hat also tatsächlich
eine art von delikt verhindert das hätte
passieren können
in los angeles ist man also davon
überzeugt dass man eine straftat
verhindern kann
noch bevor sie begangen wird dies indem
man verdächtige personen in bestimmten
krisengebieten kontrolliert
szenenwechsel hunzenschwil im kanton
aargau
hier gibt es keine gangster dieses
friedliche quartier ist auch eine risiko
zone ein algorithmus hat hier die gefahr
von einbrüchen vorhergesagt in diesem
ländlichen gebiet benutzt die polizei
das gleiche bremssystem wie in zürich
wenn sie den beginn einer reihe von
einbrüchen erkennt löst die maschine
alarm für eine zone aus die patrouillen
werden verstärkt doch auch hier zeigt
sich dass ein verbrechen nicht immer
verhindert werden kann
auch wenn die prognose stimmt ich kann
mich an einen vorfall gerinnen im
februar hat wir eine meldung ich glaube
es war in oftringen dass dort ein
kopfsalat ausgelöst hat und
schlussendlich hatten wir im verlauf der
folgenden woche hatten wir ein
entsprechendes delikt dort wir konnten
es leider nicht verhindern aber das hat
sich bestätigt dass dieses gebiet
einfach gefährdet ist
an diesem tag wird ganz in der nähe ein
alarm ausgelöst
die umgebung der autobahn a1 ist im
visier
die risikogebiete liegen oft entlang
dieser großen achse bern mit zürich
verbindet sie zieht professionelle
einbrecher an die hier am schnellsten
fliehen kann
wir kommen in das von der maschine
identifizierte risikogebiet ganz in der
nähe einer autobahn ausfahrt
diese große halle beherbergt ein
recyclingzentrum die polizei im aargau
hat ein weltweit einzigartiges system
entwickelt wenn die wahrscheinlichkeit
von einbrüchen in einer bestimmten zone
besteht wand eine app direkt auf das
mobiltelefon auf die gefahr hin die
bevölkerung zu erschrecken
wir haben uns diese überlegungen
tatsächlich gemacht erzeugen youngster
sogar panik werden wieder meldungen
neuer absätzen über einbrüche
wir haben aber gemerkt dass diese
überhaupt nicht gefallen ist die leute
sind sehr dankbar für diese
dienstleistung die reihe haben aber
gemerkt dass nämlich zu viele absetzen
dürfen zu viele meldungen ist jeder hier
damit wir halten uns drückt überprüfen
auch noch gesunde menschenverstand ob es
sinn macht eine warnung abzusetzen
die chefin dieses zentrums wurde schon
drei mal ausgeraubt sie hat auf ihrem
handy eine polizei warnung bezirk
zofingen warnung nicht dafür ein
bisschen zu bringen das ist ja nicht
weit von uns richtige werkzeugen aus
terrassentüren wirklich verschlossen
sind keine wertsachen schützen sie türen
fenster oder motto von den 17
wissen sie dass er sein könnten computer
algorithmus hat das gemacht
gefeiert eine maschine speziell hätte
gedacht dass werden irgendwelche leute
die das genau analysieren
die deutschschweizer kantone zürich
aargau und baselland welche die
prädiktive polizei verwenden finden sie
effizient andere kantone wollen nichts
davon wissen
denn die kriminalität ist in der ganzen
schweiz seit jahren tief in der
französischsprachigen schweiz beobachtet
man im moment die technologie kaufte sie
aber nicht keines der polizei kurs
verwendet einen prädiktiven algorithmus
dies weil die vorhersage immer schon ein
teil der polizeiarbeit war mit oder ohne
maschinen die erwartung einer solchen
systems ist äußerst kompliziert da die
zunahme und die verringerung von
kriminalität von vielen faktoren
abhängen
wir können nicht einfach sagen ich habe
eine polizei operation durchgeführt
menschen verhaftet und die kriminalität
um 20 prozent reduziert es gibt viele
verschiedene faktoren und methoden der
bewährt wenn wir sprechen hier über die
effektivität eines werkzeuges und nicht
über die maßnahmen da gibt es eine große
verwirrung irgendwo ein computersystem
zu installieren um zu sagen dass die
kriminalität um sechs prozent gesunken
ist das ist einfach nichts neues olivier
libaux hat ein anderes system
eingerichtet das noch immer von der
westschweizer polizei benutzt wird
ohne einen prädiktiven algorithmus aber
auch mit der möglichkeit serien von
straftaten zu identifizieren und zu
stoppen
dies dank der hinweise und spuren die in
der gemeinsamen datenbank der
französischsprachigen kantone
eingetragen sind
2016 wurden 2.500 einbruchserien
entdeckt etwa ein drittel konnten wir
dank der material spuren zu ordnen
wir sehen also dass die material spur in
unserer analyse aktivität dazu beiträgt
dass wir einen besseren überblick haben
ein besseres verständnis der kriminellen
die spuren sind sehr wichtig seien es
die spuren von sohlen dna oder bilder
das erlaubt uns eine serie überhaupt zu
erkennen erlaubt ihnen das auch eine
vorher ja natürlich denn von dem moment
an in dem wir einen seriencharakter
entdecken werden ja in dieser serie
musste entdecken und diese muster werden
sich in der zukunft wiederholen
es kommt darauf an was man unter
vorhersage versteht aber wir sind auf
jeden fall in der lage eine
orientierungshilfe zu geben in bezug auf
tendenzen zu verschiedenen phänomenen in
bestimmten serien die entdeckt wurden
[Musik]
beispielsweise dieser serie von bankomat
betrügereien aufgenommen durch
videoüberwachung
hier ist ein typischer trickbetrüger
letztlich eine bankkarte ldi der es auf
ältere leute abgesehen hat
der betrüger täuscht vor dass nach dem
weg gehen der kundin noch eine banknote
herausgekommen ist er überredet sie ihre
karte noch mal einzuführen und nutzt
diese gelegenheit und den code zu
erkennen
dann lenkt er ihre aufmerksamkeit ab und
drückt auf stop die karte kommt heraus
untersteht sie
dieses beispiel ist sehr interessant für
die definition der vorhersage um den
bankomaten herum aufmerksam sein
so haben sie ihn auf frischer tat er
genau und wie wäre es wenn sie dazu noch
praecox hätten dass ihnen den bereich
einschränkt keine chance in einem
solchen fall der eingeschränkte umkreis
her
das ist zürich schweiz interlaken genf
neuenburg und le locle und wie steht es
mit der privatsphäre
der einsatz der neuen technologien
könnte möglicherweise stark in die
privatsphäre der bürgerinnen und bürger
eingreifen
sie müssen wissen dass es leute gibt für
die eine untersuchung nicht lustig ist
wir sprechen hier über verhaftungen wenn
wir jedes mal wenn uns ein werbespot
eine wunde produkt anbietet von einer
technologie zur nächsten springen würden
brächten wir das system wirklich in
gefahr
wir würden die grundfreiheiten
unweigerlich gefährden dies geht über
den umgang mit polizeilichen
informationen hinaus sieht man hat diese
frage kommen zwangsläufig
grundfreiheiten ein zentraler begriff
dies auch weil die polizei über unsere
individuellen rechte viel macht hat
ricoh arbeitet mit anonymisierten daten
denkbar wäre so ein software system auch
für verbrechen bei denen personal daten
erfasst werden etwa drogenhandel oder
milieu delikte
doch das wäre aus datenschutzgründen zu
problematisch die bedenken wir verstehen
die ängste nirgendwo personen im
ruhestand ist das sehr heikel und
dementsprechend mir einfach nur kurz
daten anonymisiert so dass man an und
für sich denn nicht einfach einen
rückruf wegen der besseren ziel
das predictive policing die
vorausschauende polizeiarbeit soll eine
gezieltere und bessere prävention
ermöglichen
manche menschen fühlen sich dort die
verstärkte polizeipräsenz sicherer
doch bei anderen passiert das gegenteil
sie meinen es drohe mehr gefahr in
zürich arbeitet man bislang nur mit
ortsdaten für risikogebiete im ausland
bereits mit personendaten für
risikopersonen und gefährder listen
konnte es in zukunft auch in der schweiz
so schlimm ist im moment sicher wie das
ist auch dass prävention system das hier
nicht genutzt für ein niedliches zwar
stehe das machen rhein mit sauter und
personen sind bei umweltrelevanter
in zürich beobachtet ein mann die
maschine der polizei trotzdem genau und
er macht sich sorgen
ich denke diese gefahr ist real weil wir
übergeben dem computer immer mehr
entscheidungen und wir hinterfragen
diese entscheidungen gar nicht mehr also
der algorithmus bestimmt und wie
vielfach glauben wir der maschine mehr
wenn es zum beispiel um die polizeiliche
arbeit geht das dann plötzlich nur noch
maschinen entscheiden wer verhaftet
werden soll und wer nicht ist doch eine
riesige gefahr
eine maschine die zu viel macht hat ist
eine gefahr
diese gefahren sind real das eben hier
nicht mehr der mensch nicht mehr der
polizist auf der straße ist sondern
maschinen die eben den polizisten
anleiten irgendetwas zu tun
da kommen wir dann im kann ganz anderes
verhältnis zwischen dem bürger und dem
staat also da stellt sich dann wirklich
aber auch die frage ob der bürger die
bürgerin so etwas noch akzeptieren
sie werden überwacht die regierung
besitzt ein geheimes system eine
maschine die spioniert sie aus tag und
nacht ohne unterlass die maschine sieht
alles gewalttätige verbrechen die
normale bürger wie sie betreffen
verbrechen für die sich die regierung
nicht interessiert
[Musik]
könnte eine maschine ein algorithmus
unsere freiheiten bedrohen
wir fahren erneut nach kalifornien in
der nähe von san francisco an der
universität berkeley werden die neuen
technologien bereits kontrovers
diskutiert dieser mathematiker hat die
prädiktiven überwachungs algorithmen
überprüft für ihn besteht das problem
darin dass sich sowohl grob
vereinfachend als auch gefährlich sind
mehr übergeben menschliche expertise
menschliches urteil und menschliche
arbeit an einen algorithmus aber es ist
sehr schwierig einen algorithmus zur
verantwortung zu ziehen
wenn ein algorithmus aus irgendeinem
grund einer entscheidung gegen die welt
wird es sehr schwierig gegen diesen
algorithmus zu wehren wie kann man die
entscheidungen einer maschine in frage
stellen wenn sie doch neutral und
mathematisch objektiv ist der
algorithmus ist werfe wenn ich ihm genug
beispiele gebe findet heraus was zu tun
ist wenn ich den affen aber sehr
subjektive und voreingenommene beispiele
geben etwa gegen gewisse rassen gruppen
oder geschlechter dann überrascht es
nicht wenn der affe diese schlechten
gewohnheiten ebenfalls übernimmt
in der theorie ist die mathematik
neutral
aber im moment wo wir sie mit
menschlichen daten und menschlicher
subjektivität anwenden ist sie überhaupt
nicht mehr neutral
das problem mit algorithmen ist das
gleiche wie bei einem kochrezept wenn
die zutaten die wir verwenden schlecht
sind wird es das gericht aus sein
[Musik]
in der stadt auckland wenige kilometer
entfernt ist dieses risiko sehr real
in der stadt herrscht viel gewalt die
atmosphäre ist angespannt
man misstraut der polizei die wegen
rassismus korruption und exzessiver
gewaltanwendung immer wieder angeklagt
wurde
seit 14 jahren steht blend unter der
aufsicht der zentralregierung in
washington
hier gab es einen aufschrei gegen die
prädiktive polizei man hat angst davor
mit dem feuer zu spielen
wir haben hier eine polizei die sich 14
jahre lang nicht an die bundes befehle
gehalten hat dass die bürger
rechtsverletzungen der vergangenheit
betrifft
es gab einen strafprozess gegen beamte
der polizei von auckland die leuten
falsche beweise untergejubelt haben
sie hatten sie öffentlich durchsucht und
physisch angegriffen die menschen hier
erinnern sich daran und daher hat ein
teil unserer gemeinde eine gut
begründete und große angst vor dem
polizei department von auckland wenn
solche daten die grundlage des
prädiktiven polizei modells wären gäbe
es schlechte schlussfolgerungen und
schlechte vorhersagen in welchen
sensiblen zonen unsere polizei
intervenieren soll
mit anderen worten der algorithmus der
prädiktiven polizei wird immer noch
dieselben gegenden und ihrer bewohner
stigmatisieren die schwarze gemeinschaft
ist besonders abgestempelt dieser
ehemalige polizist bestätigt es uns und
das ist das was diese methode so
gefährlich macht weil die begründung der
polizei hierarchie ist wir sagen nichts
über die asse nichts über die hautfarbe
es sind nicht wir die etwas sagen
sondern der algorithmus die zahlen lügen
nicht
das ist mentale konditionierung
einige polizisten sind sehr intelligent
andere nicht aber es gibt diese mentale
konditionierung zu sagen hier steht es
schwarz auf weiß es ist wahr weil es
keine menschliche einwirkung ab der
algorithmus hat mir das gesagt also kann
es nicht voreingenommen sein kann nicht
rassistisch seien
bei der algorithmus nicht rassistisch
ist
auf einem solchen pulverfass könnte die
prädiktive polizei explosiv wird die
polizei von auckland aber hat dazu noch
keinen entscheid gefällt
man will sich hier noch nicht festlegen
wir alle schauen wie wir uns verbessern
können und die frage ist kann ein
computer etwas besser als ein mensch und
in einigen fällen kann ein computer
etwas besser als ein mensch und in
anderen fällen kann man die menschliche
komponente nicht ersetzen aber jetzt bis
zum heutigen tag hat das
polizeidepartement von auckland noch
keine definitiven antwort das predictive
politik betrifft diese diskussion führen
wir immer noch dass diese diskussion
noch geführt wird ist auch ihr verdienst
mälkiä sie will
sie ist eine anführerin der black lifes
matter bewegung
sie verteidigt die rechte der schwarzen
gemeinschaft brett pulver bereits im
budget aber unter dem druck der
aktivisten verzichtete die polizei
darauf hier geht es nicht um fairness
nicht um gerechtigkeit nicht um die
reduktion der kriminalität
es geht um das kontrollieren von
schwarzen braunen und armen leuten
es ging schon immer darum und unter
diesen bedingungen wird ihnen die
vorhersage technologie nur das sagen was
sie bereits glauben ihre vorurteile
bestärkt
egal wie der kontext ist das was sie
glauben bietet den datensatz den sie der
künstlichen intelligenz eingeben
es ist ein algorithmus und jemand muss
im programmieren die vorurteile des
programmierers werden die vorurteile der
technologie
[Musik]
bei paypal gibt es keine rasse oder
solche dinge es geht um die
lokalisierung
es gibt also keine rassen komponente es
ist ortsbezogen amerikanische städte
sind getrennt durch rasse resultieren
rassendiskriminierung wohnmöglichkeiten
und lebensbedingungen in geographischer
diskriminierung also keine rolle ob man
identifizieren der rassen merkmale
verwendet tatsache ist dass man sehr oft
aufgrund der wohngegend die rasse nennen
kann
der erfinder von pratt voll akzeptiert
die kritik aber er warnt vor nur größere
gefahr
es ist sehr wichtig zu unterscheiden ob
versucht wird vorherzusagen wer ein
verbrechen begehen wird oder wann und wo
wahrscheinlich ein verbrechen passieren
wird das sind radikal verschiedene
ansätze und beide werden aktuell
angewendet mir geht es um das wann und
wo bei beiden ansätzen gibt es bedenken
bezüglich der bürgerrechte aber das
ausmaß der besorgnis ist sehr
unterschiedlich
die prädiktive polizei der zukunft die
eine person und nicht mehr nur einen ort
ins visier nimmt findet man vielleicht
in mailand hier will man das profil von
dieben mit einem algorithmus
identifizieren
der polizist mario venturi hat dieses
system entwickelt hier in diesem büro
verfolgt sein team die räuber das system
heißt zusammen mit mathematikern hat
venturi an diesem system gearbeitet um
eine raubserie in der stadt mailand zu
stoppen
das prinzip besteht darin die bilder von
überwachungskameras zu analysieren die
haltung des räubers seine art zu
sprechen zu gehen alles zu entschlüsseln
zu qualifizieren und in die maschine
einzukleben auf diese weise wird eine
art verhaltens profil des individuums
erstellt der unterschied zwischen
anderen systemen und unserem ist dass
wir uns nicht nur auf die daten und die
orte konzentrieren und ihnen verbrechen
geschehen sondern auch auf die personen
die sie begehen
daher sammeln wir alle informationen die
mit diesen individuellen verbunden sind
die polizei zeigt uns diese bilder
die maschine hatte drei apotheken
lokalisiert wo der identifizierte räuber
möglicherweise ein delikt begehen könnte
zivilpolizisten wurden deshalb vor allen
dreien postiert sie konnten ihn einfach
am ausgang festnehmen
die geschäfte wurden mit kameras
ausgestattet um vom crm system
profitieren zu können wie in dieser
apotheke die 20 mal überfallen wurde
hier ist die kasse und die kameras sind
auf sie ausgerichtet denn manchmal
wurden die diebe die kasse sogar
physisch wegtragen
auf jeden fall sind sie interessiert an
der kasse wenn sie mir jetzt noch folgen
wollen
schauen sie hier ist eine kamera die den
eingang der apotheke abdeckt und dort
eine weitere für diese kasse weil wir in
dieser apotheke zwei kassen haben
hier ist das system für die auszeichnung
diese in der apotheke vernetzten kameras
erlaube mir alles was passiert perfekt
zu sehen wenn ich hier hinten bin ich
fühle mich sehr sicher damit ich habe
dieses system schon immer unterstützt
ich muss sagen es ist quasi perfekt
das netzwerk von kameras hat es
beispielsweise möglich gemacht diesen
raubüberfall in der apotheke von frau
racker zu lösen
für die mailänder polizei ist das system
effektiv es überhaupt viele serien wie
diese zu stoppen
trotzdem nutzt noch keine andere
italienische stadt kelheim
dennoch hat der finder mario venturi
große pläne
meine persönliche ambition als inhaber
des patents ist es auch ins ausland
exportieren zu können
also ein kommerzielles abenteuer
das könnte es möglicherweise wären aber
hier an diesem ort wenig polizist
man kennt die projekte des polizisten
aber nicht die des geschäftsmannes über
die vermarktung und das finanzielle
potenzial von pi crime erfahren wir
nichts
der zugriff auf den algorithmus ist auch
forschern verboten
dieser meilen der kriminologe durfte ihn
nicht untersuchen
es gibt hier zwei probleme
einerseits sind das kommerzielle
produkte und wie in allen kommerziellen
bereichen gibt es eine tendenz zur
geheimhaltung ein wenig wie beim rezept
von coca cola man versucht das geheim zu
halten weil man nicht will dass ein
konkurrent es verwenden könnte
einerseits ist das nun mal
andererseits ist das problematisch so zb
für systeme der prädiktiven polizei denn
sie sind anfällig für entscheidungen die
auswirkungen haben auf die sicherheit
einer stadt oder einer region und auf
die bürger selbst wer profitiert vom
algorithmus fragen zur mangelnden
transparenz und zu möglichen
interessenkonflikten stellen sich nicht
nur in meilen
jedes mal wenn polizeiarbeit mit
kommerziellen interessen verknüpft wird
haben wir ein problem wenn mehr
polizeiarbeit jemanden zu milliardär
macht dann werden wir garantiert mehr
kontrolle und überwachung sehen ob man
sie braucht oder nicht das ist genau das
problem
denn geld und profit sind ganz sicher
antrieb für die hightech polizeiarbeit
des einundzwanzigsten jahrhunderts
die finanziellen investitionen sind
enorm
die neuen technologien versprechen uns
immer mehr probleme zu lösen
die polizei der zukunft wird in der lage
sein alle unsere persönlichen daten zu
sammeln
dna augen gang gesicht fingerabdrücke
aber auch bankdaten krankenakten
telefongespräche
das ist die welt von big data eine welt
in der algorithmen jeder unserer fragen
beantworten sollen
dabei wissen die meisten kaum etwas
darüber
wird bald eine maschine all unsere
aktionen und gesten überwachen sowie in
der serie person of interest
sie werden überwacht die regierung
besitzt ein geheimes system eine
maschine sie spionierte aus tag und
nacht ohne und wir sind noch nicht so
weit wie die meisten leute denken
zurzeit ist das ungeheuer schwierig
dinge vorher zu sagen wer ein verbrechen
begehen wird oder wann und wo sie ein
verbrechen begehen werden und ich bin
nicht sicher dass es in fünf bis zehn
jahren einfacher sein wird es ist sehr
kompliziert
dazu kommt dass im menschlichen
verhalten ganz viel zufälligkeit
mitspielt und ich glaube nicht dass wir
den faktor der zufälligkeit jemals so
gut in den griff bekommen werden wie es
nötig wäre um mit genügend sicherheit
vorhersagen zu können dass jemand ein
verbrechen begehen wird
in los angeles gehen diese polizisten
alle mit ihren täglichen trackball
karten auf patrouille
trotz der befürchtungen von
bürgerrechtsaktivisten ist man hier
davon überzeugt dass in zukunft alle
polizei kurs auf die eine oder andere
weise solche mittel einsetzen werden ich
sehe keinen widerspruch
ich glaube die technologie hat die
polizeiarbeit verbessert und die
sicherheit der leute der technologie
vorurteile und voreingenommenheit
vorzuwerfen weil sie uns elektronisch
hilft halte ich für ignorant und es
würde vielleicht die leute gefährden die
zu beschützen geschworen habe auch wenn
es keine traditionelle oder menschliche
methode ist ich glaube ich würde meine
pflicht nicht erfüllen wenn ich sie
nicht benutzen bürgern die auswertung
ihrer wirksamkeit ist doch vier jahre
nach ihrer einsetzung beidrehen sehr
wichtig für mich ist sie ethisch genau
und sie spart uns sehr viel zeit
das problem ist dass nur wenige experten
verstehen wie diese software
funktioniert wir stützen uns auf
mathematische formeln und für die
polizei ist es nicht immer einfach zu
wissen wem oder worauf man vertrauen
kann aber in den straßen von remmert
wird wie in allen städten der welt der
tagesablauf der polizisten
wahrscheinlich immer etwa gleich
aussehen
es ist notwendig das auto zu verlassen
die leute anzusprechen zu diskutieren
kurz menschlich zu bleiben und das wird
keine maschine ersetzen können dieser
junge latino wurde gerade in einem von
brett toll genannten gebiet verhaftet er
ist schuldig zur falschen zeit am
falschen ort gewesen zu sein und die
falsche ethnische zugehörigkeit zu haben
mitten im territorium der gangs wird er
verdächtigt
seine schwester verteidigt ihn sie
schwört er habe nichts getan
aber wie kann man gegen die vorhersage
einer maschine vorgehen
in den vereinigten staaten in der
schweiz oder in italien ist die
technologie bereits vorhanden aber es
bestehen grosse gesetzeslücken
es existiert noch kein gesetz und sie zu
reglementieren
wie ist noch mal ihr name
und trotzdem die polizei von morgen ist
heute schon unterwegs